oh hi I didn't see you there my name is
Adam Simone and I'm a co-founder of the
leaf shade company now most people think
that they have their best ideas while in
the shower
lucky for me I get my best ideas while
shaving so we started with the problem
disposable cartridges cost way too much
money they're environmentally unfit and
they're one size fits all so that's
where the good ideas came into play you
see our first idea was to build a lawn
mower for your face genius but you
didn't think of something every time you
needed a shave you'd have to go out to
the gas station and fill it up yeah so
that's not gonna work our next idea fire
so we realize that fire needs oxygen to
survive unfortunately we breed carbon
dioxide so that doesn't work either
and our last idea this is the one that's
going to eliminate shaving forever be
ready face hats yep
can you see it I can well none of those
really worked out so we built a razor